a los que un ingeniero ciencia
tecnología y sociedad
venimos hablando de ciencia y tecnología
durante muchísimos años la tecnología
es sorprendente como la ciencia y
tecnología
los ingenieros
cuando vemos entonces pensamos
también vamos también regimos eso
significa que cualquiera de nosotros
acabo de hablar de esa ciudad
la tecnología es cuando pensamos
estamos en su teoría cuando pensamos en
ello recordamos una vez
[Música]
quién conoce todos los universos quiere
hablar todo aquello que nos hacen
físicos
eso es lo que buscamos la humanidad
una máquina de flacso suiza donde
buscamos partículas
sin embargo buscamos una partícula que
todos y somos usados con movilidad
cuando empezamos a calcular la relación
de los 10 677 somos bastante bastante
aceptados hoy sabemos a ciencia cierta
que son 300.000 menos
pero sorprendentes
y esta ciencia entonces no quiero que
nos olvidemos
es importante
les invito a que sigan viajando y
tecnología
cuando hablamos en que son instrumentos
[Música]
después decidimos buscar otras opciones
y pasamos a una máquina
le llamamos la máquina de toro
la ciencia de la computación hacia otras
veces próximamente y dijimos la máquina
que todo lo puede
porque todo lo necesita
avanzamos industria 4.0 cuando creamos
industria 4.033 tecnologías sensores y
hoy hablamos de industria es que cuando
ustedes
cada vez
es muy sencillo
consultar
lo que es importantísmo interpretarlos
entonces la tecnología
si queremos nosotros te diría lo que
quiere de nosotros
si seguimos caminando vamos a través de
sociedad eso sí gracias a lo que sabemos
hacer todo
todos sabemos sociedad aquí pasamos
juntos hacemos una reunión salir nos
aprendemos en nosotros y ellos
naturalmente humana
les contamos ejemplos clarísimos ninguno
de los dos es importante que los pliegos
existen banco del tiempo entonces lo que
hacemos es intercambiar ideas sin tener
conocimiento lo que hacemos es intentar
viaje experiencia en quilá si sin
utilizar mil tambores con el dinero
utilizando algo más importante nuestro
tiempo su tiempo y a veces hacemos
escuelas comunitarias están los niños y
conversamos con ellos y los ancianos
despreciamos otros ellos y nosotros lo
mismo en cuatro proyecto de un colectivo
que se llama confían el proyecto se
llama cultivo y lo que hacemos es
preguntarnos qué queremos desde sociedad
civil como construimos desde abajo como
empezamos a construir desde nosotros y
no desde arriba por eso es que ensucian
de parece sumamente importante que vemos
que se acabó el tiempo de grandes
motivos y que es hora de actuar y hoy es
el momento
hablar es hermoso pero si no hacemos
algo así
por esta distorsión entre ciencia que
conquistó ciudades algo sorprendente
muchas la ciencia
sí
[Música]
y totalmente pensar en una letra no
quien está sentado
lo que tenemos que tener clarísimo acá
es que la ciencia que tenemos ahí
mágicamente no les va a producir
tecnología y que la tecnología
mágicamente no les va a dar bienestar es
decir no les va a sociedad
cómo producimos quienes en otra sociedad
también de espacio donde estamos donde
estamos
esta es la situación de ciencia
tecnología y sociedad
cuando pensaba en la misma máquina de
los nazis y en la segunda
en ciencia seguramente es bueno como
parece
cuando sucedió a su máquina se le
acredita prácticamente en 26 años
la humanidad
ninguna importancia y dos personas o
tres
esta interacción debemos aprender a
criticar sobre todo cuando mantienen
estructuras de poder no podemos permitir
que la ciencia de la tecnología mantenga
estructuras de poder no nos lo podemos
permitir
quieren que ayudamos a crecer con la
sociedad
entonces les terminó hoy y creo que es
la herramienta más importante desechado
queremos su promesa por eso es lo que
queremos adelantar si mirar atrás sin ir
adelante
olvidándonos de los bajado y no pensando
en nuestro futuro estamos 100% seguros
de que progresar por progresar yo me
esfuerzo les propongo que hablemos de
ciencia tecnología y de sociedad como un
producto cultural es decir que desde
nosotros empezamos a conversar
vamos a los 50 piñas que jamás van a
salir para nada
en ese lugar siempre y cuando nosotros
decidamos que estos objetivos de
desarrollo está con nosotros también
como parte del mundo
y es por eso que este viaje a través de
los ojos de un ingeniero es decir vivir
más que unos y ceros
[Aplausos]